all right our next guest burst on the
national scene by leading Alabama to
victory in the 2017 national title game
went on to throw 87 touchdowns 11
interceptions with the Crimson Tide but
let's be honest some of those receivers
were catching five yard passes and
taking it to the house but his greatest
achievement just might be making
Alabama's offense fun to watch for the
first time ever
please welcome
[Applause]
just so you know to it
everybody gets roasted like that that
you know we're just having a little bit
of fun you made Alabama's offense
entertaining for the first time ever
that's good to see you good to see you
look good thank you you look good did
you you know you wanted to go to USC
you've told us about this you loved Matt
liner did you worry about the Alabama
offense being kind of boring I'm not
really you know I think the what what
kind of went into that deciding factor
was was my my father you know we took a
visit out there we really only took
about three visits you know and that was
the USC UCLA in Alabama so I mean I I
did I couldn't really gauge you know
what was good what wasn't good because I
heard organ had a great facility to so
how did you pass up on us see if Matt
Leinart
is your idol yeah that's a great
question I think that's one for my dad
for me so my mom I am my dad is kind of
I don't spot here but yeah I was
wondering about that that you loved
liner USC you had an opportunity to go
there and then you end up in Alabama
I don't know that worked out but it I'm
fine with it now how's your health it's
good thank you
yeah yeah thank you for asking but it's
good what what are the markers here
where he had time lines that the doctor
has helped you with on when you'll be
able to give so up to this point I think
what we're waiting for is the
three-month mark so not this upcoming
Monday but you know the following Monday
from from this upcoming Monday which
would which would kind of be the
three-month mark and it kind of tells us
you know how everything is so we have
our CT scan you know and then I think we
have a follow up with MRI and you know
depending on how well all of those
things are you know it determines on
whether we you know can go ahead and do
training or gradually work you know into
you know the pro day and and whatnot but
you know as as far as you know a health
standpoint um I mean I'm I'm on pace to
full recovery so it's
how much you know about the hip now you
an expert on hips
I wouldn't say an expert but you know
from from not knowing too much about
hips you know and then getting you know
the injury I mean I'd I'd say I'm at
least I'm at least graduating from from
an amateur side what do you think teams
are gonna ask you well I think they're
gonna ask me everything in the book you
know from my health I mean what I know
in football too you know I guess the
relationships I built and at Alabama
relationships I built off the field I
know just everything you know and I they
know the answers I'm pretty sure they
know the answers to every questions
they're gonna ask but I mean it it could
vary high I think
but do you look at did you know how
serious that injury was as soon as it
happened I didn't I didn't I I really
didn't what did it feel like well I
couldn't really comprehend everything
because I think my body was in shock you
know you know when I got to Birmingham
and I was in the hospital bed that's
that's kind of when you know I could
kind of evaluate you know everything and
kind of realize that you know this is
very serious that's when I you know
found out from the doctors that I
wouldn't be able to finish out the
season with my teammates and that was
hard that was hard you know because we
we worked so hard you know we came off a
loss the previous year you know with our
national championship game and now we're
hoping to win one this past year but but
we came up short so should you be the
number one quarterback drafted you know
that's a good question I think I think
that's for everyone else to decide I
don't think that's you're like you're
the best quarterback honestly that's I
it's hard for me to talk about myself
you know so I know you're a humble guy
but but but you have to be confident at
this next show for sure and and I think
confidence comes in different ways you
know and my confidence is in with me
telling everyone how good I am
okay just if you give me that
opportunity I'm going
and you know hopefully put our team in
the in the best position to become
successful who do you admire who do you
look at and say yeah I admire guys guys
like Drew Brees and Russell Wilson you
know I kept in contact with them you
know throughout this this previous
season but you know I look up to guys
like that not because of what they do on
the field but because of who they are
off the field you know they're guys that
the younger generation can emulate
they're guys that I can emulate you know
just the way they walk the way they talk
the way they hold themselves I mean they
hold themselves to a high standard but
at the same time they're so gracious
when it comes to you know talking to
other people or you know just just going
about doing things so those are the guys
that I kind of look up to an NFL scout
said that if you go to the combine you
won't be able to throw at the combine
more than likely right
yeah that's great okay he said that we
want to get his medicals we want to get
him on a white board and have him design
you know plays yeah and then we want to
talk to him so that you know that's why
they said you know going to the combine
even if he doesn't work out we want to
know who he is we also want to know how
he could diagram a play if we throw
something up there are you ready for
that the whole whiteboard thing yeah I'd
say I'm ready I think that's what we've
been given
you know while we were at Alabama you
know get up on the whiteboard rob plays
well wait wait how would coach do that
Mike Cozart yeah so so usually at the
end of our kind of film session you know
when we have like let's say 20 minutes
30 minutes okay guys get on the board so
I'd be the starter the second starter
and then the third star so this past
year it was me it was Mac and then it
was my you know my little brother I mean
he give us a play we'd write out the
name of the play right out the formation
I mean draw where everyone goes and then
you know the protection you know okay so
if this guy comes what are you doing you
know okay we flip the protection so we
send the protection this way okay this
guy comes down on this coverage you know
where are you going
oh we're going here so I mean you know
I'd say those those guys there at the
University I've prepared us you know for
something okay are you
good big brother well I'm a fair big
brother I'd say fair fair big brother
are you tough on your brother I'm tough
I'm very tough on yes sir do you do you
are you like paint news to Eli where you
kind of rough him up or haze him a
little bit there make fun of him nah I'm
not I'm not more so than you know make
fun but you know I just don't want to be
one of you know those brothers we're
okay I'm gonna tell you what you want to
hear you know I'm gonna tell you know
the things you you want to hear but not
tell you the things you don't want to
hear you know I think I think when you
continue to tell your little brothers
like oh you're doing good you know
you're doing good when really they're
not it kind of sets them up for failure
it kind of cripples them because in
their mind they're thinking what what
they're doing is right when really it
isn't and so I think the biggest thing
for my brother when everyone asked me
you know if he's gonna be the starter I
mean he's gonna have to work just like
everyone else you know in that in that
organization he's gonna have to compete
and he's gonna have to earn the job so
that's that's that's just how it's gonna
be you know that level of the next level
and then life after football so he's a
to Otunga below the former Alabama
quarterback joining us on behalf of auto
trader all right let me see how you do
as a spokesperson part of me let me see
how you do as a spokesperson here whoa
yeah so I'm here on behalf of auto
trader you know and coming from Hawaii
to Alabama I mean or just being in
college you know one of the first things
I'd say you know you need is
transportation you know to get from
point A to point B and so what me and my
family did was we went on auto trader
and auto trader helped us I mean you
know with with car shopping and he made
it that much easier what kind of car you
go I have a Jeep right now I have a Jeep
and so you know what also helpful is
Kelley Blue Book yeah you know with
Kelley Blue Book they helped with the
pricing and I mean it all of that made
it that much easier for me and my family
and so all we had to do was call up the
dealership I mean go down there take a
look at the car test drive it you know
I'm with the help of my grandparents as
well you know I was able to get my first
car so now thanks to auto trader and
blueblood I know that you wear your
faith well on your body you got a cross
on your your wrist there did you ever
question your faith when you got hurt I
actually didn't question my faith you
know after I got hurt with the hip
injury you know I'd say for me I think
my injury touched more lives than me
playing on the field I say that because
my injury kind of showed my faith in a
bigger sense than me playing on the
field you know am i playing everyone you
know that that has been fans of Alabama
football or fans of us you know they it
it just gives them a good feeling you
know when we score when we win you know
but to the people who actually go
through injuries as well you know and to
see how you know we I kind of handled it
and went about it you know it I'd say we
got a lot more feedback you know as far
as you know faith based people you know
with how how I went about doing it with
my my rehab with how I know did it while
I was injured you're such a humble guy
and you know there's when you were on
the last time we couldn't help but hear
Russell Wilson in you so I like
confident but humble are you cocky in
the huddle like if we're if I'm on the
field with you and we're in the huddle
like are you different personality I
mean I I'd say I'm the same I'm the same
I'd say on the sidelines you know like
we love to have fun but if we're kinda
in the situation where we're losing then
like that's when kind of step up and say
all right guys now's not the time to
start laughing like you know are you
gonna have a favorite save and story
that you're allowed to tell to your
grandkids can you tell it now like you
just say favorite Saban story yeah I
don't have a favorite saving stories and
you're not allowed to imitate him oh
well you can't no I well I
I'm not good at imitating anyway so okay
all right but I'd say a pretty cool
savings story is you know in the spring
Coach Saban you know I mean me and him
were close and whatnot but when it when
it came time to spring kind of summer
break
you know the may break we have I mean
coach Coach Saban would just text you
know like how you doing just see how I
was doing he'd call and um something
that's pretty funny was Coach Saban
called you know and I answered and I was
like what's up coach he was like hey
what's up buddy you know how's
everything
tell him it's good you know and then he
brings up Game of Thrones he's like you
know we just you know from there we just
started talking about Game of Thrones
and so you know I think people watch
Game of Thrones yeah yeah okay and so I
think people look at Coach Saban as
someone who's really strict you know
really hard on the players when really
there's there's time for for everything
you know on the field straight business
off the field he's a very personable
person I mean he really cares about his
players he cares about his coaching
staff it's like you know summer camp you
know he could yell at me the entire
practice then once once practice is over
like you know he's like joking with you
you know and everyone's laughing and
you're confused because two minutes ago
he was he was just yelling at you Josh
Jacobs was telling us that story about
what did he drop deez nuts
he's teased on that before do you you
can confirm what your dad's here I don't
know if you want Josh Derrick Henry
might be able to confirm that yeah well
I've heard it
for sure and it's one of those things
where you know you're like about to take
the snap and then he makes the joke and
you're like Autotrader they teamed up to
help make to his car buying process
easier as he becomes a pro the largest
variety of cars Kelly Blue Book price
advisor on every listing you can be
confident you're getting the most
trusted pricing on your next vehicle
purchase with Auto Trader it's great to
see I don't know are you looking for
real estate in Miami because you n could
end up playing here yeah I mean can't
help but root for you I think you'd be a
great face for a franchise and we
appreciate the time when you were at
Alabama and we wish you the best of luck
here with your next step
thank you guys thank you too for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
channel 239 on Direct TV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]